and here he is the man of the hour
getting ready to accept his glue and nil
check for a thousand dollars as the
toughest player on planet earth
presented by gorilla glue here on the
rich eisen show give a round of applause
andrew verstardous university of
michigan center oh yeah what's up andrew
how are you
hey i'm doing great i'm doing great how
about yourself yeah you're doing great
yeah you're doing great all right let's
get into this thing first here
uh it you are you're a sixth year senior
who walked on to michigan that's a true
story right
yes serious sir okay so walk me through
how when how did this all start for you
andrew it all started when i was a
little my mom's family's from michigan i
grew up in virginia though so i was
brainwashed by that side of the family
who loved michigan from a young age
right
so uh
you know i'm through recruiting it was
always in the back of my mind that if i
could come here i would and i got the
opportunity to come here as a walk-on
and you know
came here with big dreams was definitely
humbled a lot because of you know the
past great d linemen playing scout team
all those years right but uh you know
just
loved every minute of it tried to make
most of every opportunity one day at a
time
and uh you know building trusts with the
coaches and the players and now it's
just one big family and i think
you know that trust is what kind of
fueled us this year you know and it's
been a long time in the process you know
so
something good always takes time to make
of course no doubt about that so um
when did you first walk on to campus
then when would you first get to
michigan what year oh shoot uh 2016.
okay so does that mean you were there
for my speech for my honorary captaincy
andrew was that absolutely yeah
okay
wow so
uh
i i can't believe somebody's still
around that long that's incredible so uh
how how how uh how inspiring was i
andrew let's be honest here let's make
it about
exactly deeply moved
good answer
good answer good afternoon
wow
gosh darn it so then i i guess how how
um
when did things begin to turn where you
realized i can actually become a starter
on this team and get a c
on my chest and start uh you know
and start blowing open holes for the
university of michigan's running game
what about that
um you know kind of like i said i just
started trying to get better every day
especially going against such a good
deal on scout my scout team you know i
would uh just take hits but you know
it's the little victories and then just
keep stacking those up and
you know big thing right here is
consistency i just tried to be
consistent and
you know as that got better i had great
uh great players to play behind you know
caesar and ben and so many other guys
running
but um
and mike and all those guys but
you know kind of learning from them
watching them and then
you know uh once they left it just came
time for opportunity and you know just
taking advantage of every opportunity i
mean
you know the help that i've been here
for so long i know the playbook
i would think pretty well but i mean
just you know
really just giving it all i had every
day and
i really just live by that because
you know can't really waste this life
and this has been a big part of my life
football for so long so just take
advantage of every opportunity day to
day and just enjoying the heck out of it
andrew for stardust the toughest player
on planet earth this week university of
michigan center fresh off of
beating ohio state for the first time in
his
six years at the school right here on
the rich eisen show okay so let's let's
get into that day
when you woke up and you saw the snow
and
you got to the stadium
wha what was the feeling like
for you and the rest of your teammates
that day where you knew this was a
running day this was a slate gray day
this is a
michigan versus ohio state day walk me
through that
yeah i mean we woke up
got down to breakfast and i like saw the
other guys and i knew we were dialed in
i knew uh
knowing all year this team is different
but uh you know you see the snow and as
alignment you just see the smile and the
crazy thing was like it wasn't just
linemen everyone was pumped about it you
know um
we kind of get going with the day we're
fired up just dialed in
and you know just keeps coming down
keeps coming down so uh you know
everyone's looking their chops ready to
go at it because um like i said this
team just prepares its butt off and
we're eager for every opportunity and
you know especially
finally to get that done finally to get
the chance to
you know redeem ourselves you know go
out and take it it was uh
everyone's just dialed in that's all i
can say
when you say it's different i mean
that's the conversation you know we in
the fan base and the alumni base and the
media have been talking about all year
that it's different what do you mean
different how is it different this team
from previously um you know
people call it teamwork and all that
good stuff and that's really what it is
but it's really just individual
relationships between staff members
staffs and players players ourselves
just there's trust there there's there's
love there and everything is
you know done trying to bring up the guy
beside you trying to
do your best for the man beside you
that's that's top down and you know
there's been flashes here and there but
i've never been a part of uh
a team a unit
that's been this much of a family with
this many like tight relationships you
know and this guys truly playing for
each other and
um you know the execution's just been
continuing to get better and better but
you know everything really stemmed just
from that bond that relates those
relationships do you have any idea what
you've done to make me per and the rest
of michigan alums happy andrew vestas do
you have any idea
any inkling
um trust me i'm i'm just as if not way
more happy because
so a long time coming a lot of blood
swung cheers from this whole team this
whole family and it's just
it's right it's all in front of us we
just got to take advantage of every
opportunity yeah i mean what's what's
the conversation like you know there's
another game here you can't take a
victory lap there's there's uh there's
there's a whole setup that's already
happened and now the opportunity for you
to take what's that conversation like
absolutely i mean you know you had your
24 hours to celebrate and it was a fun
24 hours but we walked in the building
uh sunday afternoon yesterday and it's
just you know back to business um how
can we prepare the best way we can
and that's something we've been doing
we've been loving the process love and
preparation and
guys just right back to where we were
you know perfect preparation and perfect
mindset to get ready for the game
and so like i said guys are getting
dialed in already it's awesome i love it
and then the mentality that you had in
the third and fourth quarter against
ohio state andrew uh where haskins just
kept on plowing right behind you guys uh
coram as well um and the rest of your
team pulling together
did did you get the sense of ohio state
wanted none of that did you get that
sense third fourth quarter
andrew
uh yeah i mean
i'll tell you what when it's the five
linemen blocking and then tight ends
blocking and receivers blocking and then
running backs just making it happen
and taking advantage when we did throw
the ball you know just we were executing
we were clicking and i think you know
you just
you get to a point where you run the
ball that much you're swearing people
down and
you know um
i think we just played our football we
played the type of football that we love
we were ourselves and you know it just
it
it's hard to beat when you execute that
well is this your first nil deal is this
your first name image and likeness deal
andrew vista uh this is like the second
one
he's been doing some little uh
uh wings on the side but you know i'm
excited some wings on the side here's
what we're giving you some glue to go
with your wings sir and now hey it's
been six years got to keep the body
together i love it yeah absolutely is
there anything in your in your world
that needs fixing andrew anything oh
shoot i'll find something
okay very good i'm very excited for you
andrew thanks very much congratulations
on the win against ohio state you really
and the rest of your teammates have made
the entire fan base and alumni base so
euphoric and
we're even more excited about what's to
come this saturday against the iowa
hawkeyes and then
you know knocking on wood beyond so
thank you really appreciate it
absolutely thanks for having me and
thanks for all the support and
right back at you that's andrew
vestardus the gorilla glue toughest
player on planet earth for this week
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here